-Five conservative justices
on the Supreme Court
are apparently poised
to overturn Roe v. Wade
and erase women's constitutional
right to bodily autonomy,
subverting the will of
the vast majority of Americans
and defying a half century
of legal precedent.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
As everyone undoubtedly
knows by now,
five Republicans
on the Supreme Court
appear poised to strike down
Roe v. Wade
and erase abortion rights,
in a ruling that would deprive
tens of millions of women
their fundamental right
to make healthcare decisions
for themselves.
We know that from
a truly stunning leak
of a draft opinion.
And while there
have been leaks before,
a leak of this magnitude
seems virtually unprecedented
in the history of the court.
-It is cataclysmic, I think,
for the reputation of the court
and even for the internal
operations of the court.
This is how they do their work.
They do it in secrecy.
I cannot think of another time
where a full draft opinion
has leaked early
in the process like this.
You cannot understate --
overstate how big a deal this is
for how the court operates.
The trust is shattered.
And I think it's going
to take a long time
for the court
to recover from this.
-Oh, I'm sorry to hear that
their trust has been shattered.
How will they ever recover
from this breach
of their personal privacy?
Maybe Samuel Alito can start
wearing a shirt that says,
"My judicial body, my choice."
We never get -- we never get
this sort of inside look.
We never get this sort
of inside look
at the private machinations
of the court.
It's a secretive institution
of unaccountable
lifetime appointees.
They don't want you to know what
they're up to behind the scenes,
especially in a case like this.
Seeing one of their draft
opinions before it's published
is like seeing your gym teacher
in a liquor store,
or like seeing
a Taco Bell employee
lead a horse into the kitchen.
"Whoa, whoa!
Whoa! Steady, Chalupa!
It's gonna be fine."
And you know what?
Maybe the institution deserves
to be shattered a little bit.
You could argue
it was already shattered
a long time ago
by cynical Republicans
who spent decades turning it
into a political weapon
by defiling the Constitution,
stealing Supreme Court seats,
and forcing their nominees
onto the bench
through the exercise
of raw power.
Remember when Lindsey Graham
went on an unhinged
partisan screed
to get the "I like beer" guy
on the court?
I mean, look at his face.
Does this look like
the face of a guy
who cares about the integrity
of our institutions?
He looks like he's auditioning
to play the villain
in a Tennessee Williams play.
[ As Graham ]
Meemaw, I swear by God,
I'll get my revenge on you
for telling me
I'll never make it out
of this one-horse town --
No-horse town?!
What happened to Chalupa?
He made a run for the border?!
[ Normal voice ] And yet
it won't surprise you to learn
that even as they appear poised
to shred the fundamental rights
of tens of millions of women
and reap their biggest
political victory in 50 years,
conservatives are still whining
and casting themselves
as victims
because of the leak.
-There has to be
consequences, Harmeet,
for this individual,
whoever it was.
The Chief Justice,
it's incumbent upon him
to bring every law clerk
before him --
"Give me your phones."
I'm sorry. Or the FBI.
"Give me your phone.
We want all your accounts.
We got to do our own...
You know, we have to do
our own...
look at every device
that you've ever used
and find out who did this."
-I like that they just pan
over the Supreme Court justices
like they're like,
"It could be you!
It could be you.
Was it you?"
"The privacy of the court
has been violated,
and nothing is more sacred
than privacy.
So give me your phone!
We want all your accounts!
Your Uber, your Pinterest,
your Seamless account.
I want to know if you've been
ordering suspicious woke foods
like green juices
or quinoa burgers."
And how do you know
it's a liberal?
It could have just as easily
been a conservative --
[ Coughs ]
Ginni Thomas --
who leaked the opinion
to freeze the majority in place
and stop the Chief Justice
John Roberts,
from trying to convince one of
the other court's conservatives
to soften their stance.
I have no idea.
But the fact that they're all
freaking out about the leak
instead of celebrating
the victory is telling.
It underscores yet again
that even at the height
of their powers,
these people always
have to play the victim.
If they won a free car
on "Wheel of Fortune,"
they'd immediately
start whining,
"But I already have
two cars in my garage!
I don't have space
for a brand-new Stingray.
This is so unfair!"
And if that doesn't strike you
as an insane reaction,
here's something
even more unhinged --
Fox News personalities
referring to a leak
of an unclassified document
as an "insurrection."
-This is an insurrection
against the court,
and it needs to be found
who did it,
and whatever legal means
can be taken against them
needs to be taken.
-I am so glad that Ari
used the term insurrection.
That's exactly what it is.
But let's take it
one step further.
This is an insurrection
not by some guy from some state
who got hot under the collar
and went to D.C.
and got overheated at a rally.
This is insurrection by a person
who is paid for by the taxpayers
and who has a duty
under his particular job
and employment
to keep his mouth shut.
And he didn't do it.
So it's an egregious form,
if you will, of insurrection.
And I hope that everyone
will use that term,
because if what happened
January 6th was an insurrection,
this absolutely
is an insurrection.
-First of all,
total side note here,
but what's with the beard,
Mike Huckabee?
You look like
a hillbilly Santa Claus.
"Ho, ho, ho!
Merry Christmas.
Here's a pack of cigarettes
and a Dr. Seuss book
with the racist stuff
still in there."
Second, do you think you guys
might be projecting a bit
with this insurrection nonsense?
Leaking a document
is not an insurrection.
January 6th,
when a mob of rioters
violently stormed the Capitol,
that was an insurrection.
In this case, someone posted
a piece of paper online.
Here, I'll prove
which one is worse.
Do you think Mike Pence
would rather be whisked
out of a building
by Secret Service
while a mob chanted
"Hang Mike Pence"
or read a leaked memo
that said "Hang Mike Pence"?
Do all these pundits whining
about the leak really think
this is what will shatter
the integrity of the court?
Not the fact that
Republicans stole a seat
from President Obama or the fact
that several of their nominees
apparently lied to the Senate
about their positions on Roe,
or the fact that one of them
called opposition
to his nomination
based on credible
sexual assault allegations
a smear campaign orchestrated
by shadowy left-wing groups
and the Clintons?
I could go on, so I will.
The fact they rushed
through another nominee
a little over a week
before the election,
a nominee whose ceremony turned
out to be a superspreader event
and who posed
for a political photo op
with the president
after her confirmation,
or the fact that another justice
declined to recuse himself
from a case that potentially
involved text messages
sent by his wife that would
reveal her involvement
in attempts to overthrow
a presidential election
and install Donald Trump
as an unelected autocrat,
or the fact that one of them
apparently got caught
flushing a toilet
during an oral argument
conducted via telephone?
-And what the FCC has said
is that when...
[ Toilet flushes ]
...the subject matter of a call
ranges to such topics,
then the call is transformed.
-Can you imagine how jarring
that must have been
for the lawyers in
the middle of their arguments?
I mean, it would definitely
throw me if out of nowhere
I heard a toilet flush
off-camera.
[ Toilet flushes ]
Who was that?
-Sorry, Seth.
-Wally, did you go
to the bathroom
during "A Closer Look"?
-Yeah. You were just
on one of your rants.
-Alright, you know...
[ Laughter ]
The point is, we don't know
if this ruling
will change at all
before it's published, or how.
But what we do know is
that this is the culmination
of a decades-long effort
by conservatives
to turn the court
into a political weapon
and aim it straight
at abortion rights.
They've been plotting this
out in the open for decades.
As early as 1989,
there were four conservative
justices on the court
who made it clear that they were
ready to overturn Roe
and essentially invited
anti-choice activists
to help them by proposing
new restrictions on abortion.
-From almost day one
after Roe was decided
by the Supreme Court,
legislators who opposed abortion
came in and tried
to pass restrictions.
-In 1989, a Supreme Court
decision known as Webster
gave the pro-life movement
a boost
when four justices indicated
they were ready to consider
overturning Roe v. Wade.
-What Webster did
is it emboldened
those who wanted
to push the question.
And it said to them,
"Okay. It's alright.
There's four votes here
on this court to overrule Roe.
We can pass bans on abortion.
Let's do that
and get the question
directly before the court."
-That was 1989.
You know how long ago that was?
Just to give you an idea, here's
what I looked like in 1989.
[ Laughter ]
This is what
the conservative movement,
a radical minority
deeply at odds
with the vast majority
of voters,
has been working towards
for 50 years.
And that's why they made
their Faustian bargain
with an obviously monstrous
individual in Donald Trump,
so they could finally cement
that majority.
To them, he was just
the final piece,
the culmination of a scheme
that had been out in the open
since at least the Reagan era.
It's why they stood with him
through all his many
deprivations and indignities
and numbed themselves
to his many crimes and abuses,
so they could finally
achieve this outcome
they've been working toward
for half a century.
In fact, Trump made
the bargain explicit.
He repeatedly told Republicans
they had to vote for him
even if they didn't like him
in order to get
the judges they wanted.
-If you really like
Donald Trump, that's great.
But if you don't,
you have to vote for me anyway.
You know why?
Supreme Court judges.
Have no choice.
Sorry, sorry.
[ Chuckles ]
Sorry. You have no choice.
-He sounds like the only kid
on your block who has a pool.
"Sorry, but if you want
to use the pool,
you got to be friends with me.
Sorry! Sorry.
And I'm hearing it's gonna
be 88 and sunny all week long,
so..."
[ Laughter ]
Trump ripped the mask off
the Republican Party
because there were times
when Republicans and leaders
of the religious right tried
to play coy, lying to us about
what they were actually up to
and insisting ludicrously
that they weren't really going
to outlaw abortion.
They know it's deeply unpopular
and far outside the mainstream
of public opinion.
An NPR poll in 2019 found
that only 13% of Americans
supported overturning Roe.
13%.
For context, the movie "Gigli"
has a 13% audience rating
on Rotten Tomatoes.
I love that movie.
It's not good, but anytime
my wife and I hit a rough patch,
we lock eyes and say,
"If they can get over that..."
So, they knew this is
a massively unpopular move,
which is why even as they
plotted out in the open
for years to overturn Roe,
they also insisted to us
that we were ridiculous
for thinking abortion rights
were at stake.
It's why Kavanaugh and
Neil Gorsuch lied to the Senate,
or why the co-chair of Trump's
evangelical advisory board
said in 2018, "The left
is going to try very hard
to say this is all about
overturning Roe."
But Trump threw all that
out the window,
when, in a craven bid to grovel
for the support
of the religious right,
he just came out and said
he would appoint pro-life judges
who would overturn Roe.
-Do you want to see
the court overturn Roe v. Wade?
-Well, if we put another two
or perhaps three justices on,
that's really what's going
to be -- that will happen.
And that'll happen
automatically, in my opinion,
because I am putting pro-life
justices on the court.
Having to do with abortion,
when it --
if it ever were overturned,
it would go back to the states.
So, it would go back
to the states.
-But then some women won't
be able to get an abortion.
-No, it'll go back
to the states.
-By state -- no, some...
-Well, they'll perhaps
have to go to another --
they'll have to go
to another state.
-And that's okay?
-Well, we'll see what happens.
-He's so cavalier about a woman
needing to cross state lines
for access
to lifesaving healthcare.
It's maddening when someone
who loses his [bleep]
over even the smallest slights
tells you the thing you're
worried about is no big deal.
Remember, this is a guy who,
if a restaurant didn't have
the right ketchup for his steak,
would bitch about it at rallies
for the next year and a half.
[ As Trump ] They said,
"We're sorry, Mr. Trump.
We don't have Heinz.
We only have Hunt's."
And I said, "Hunt's?
That's not a real ketchup."
We know that about Hunt's.
I hate to say it, but it's not.
We love Heinz.
Don't we love Heinz?
[ Normal voice]
Trump ripped the mask off
the entire corrupt enterprise
and just laid out
the devil's bargain
he made with the GOP,
for all to see.
He even said explicitly the list
of judges would be chosen
by the conservative
Federalist Society.
I doubt he even read that list.
He probably just
picked a name off it
the way your aunt orders
a fun cocktail on vacation.
"Oh, a Horny Caterpillar.
Don't mind if I do."
Which is why
it's all the more grotesque
and absurd for Republicans
who supported nominees
like Neil Gorsuch
or Brett Kavanaugh
to suddenly claim now
that they're shocked
by what's happening.
-Today, Senator Collins
reacted to the news
with a brief statement
saying in part, quote,
"If this leaked draft opinion
is the final decision
and this reporting is accurate,
it would be
completely inconsistent
with what Justice Gorsuch
and Justice Kavanaugh
said in their hearings
and in our meetings
in my office," unquote.
Senator Murkowski today, too,
also suggested that
Gorsuch and Kavanaugh
perhaps had not been fully
honest about their positions.
-If it goes in the direction
that this leaked copy
has indicated,
I will just tell you
that it -- it...
it rocks my confidence
in the court right now.
-I'm sorry, THIS rocks
her confidence in the court?
And when you found out
the tooth fairy wasn't real,
did that rock your confidence
in dentistry?
"Wait a second,
then where the hell have
all my teeth been going?!"
I for one don't believe
they're this gullible.
I think they knew
it would come to this
and now they want
to feign surprise,
because for all their talk
about snowflakes,
Republicans take the cake
every time.
"You were mean to my friend
who was applying
for a lifetime appointment."
"You leaked a document
that rolled back women's rights
half a century."
"How were we supposed to know
a thing that was going to happen
that everyone said
was going to happen?"
"Why does it smell
like guacamole in here?"
Republicans have been playing
the long game
and plotting this for decades.
The only way to combat them
is to take the fight head-on,
to enshrine a woman's right
to choose in federal law,
stand up
for the majority of Americans
who oppose this
extremist ruling,
and make it an issue
Republicans can't dodge.
We can't just
sit around and hope
Alito will take his draft
opinion and do this to it.
-...the subject matter
of a call...
[ Toilet flushes ]
...ranges to such topics...
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over 2 million meals
a year to men,
women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.